you can hear me fine with this okay
great
don't see my name is Nadia sunny and I'm
a research scientist at UC San Diego I'm
also data scientist at the Open Medicine
Institute in Mountain View and I do
anything else related to data science
and machine learning and today I'd like
to talk about the situation where we use
exploratory data analysis for pretty
much all their science problems but in
particular for images and documents and
so this situation you might run into
because you'll see that this is one of
the base classes and scikit-learn it's a
transformer class and the data type that
it expects from your or your transform
method is this numpy array that has to
have n samples institute two-dimensional
array basically where you have rows and
columns right and so most machine
learning algorithms expect construct
this rows and columns kind of thing but
there's plenty of cases where that's the
type of data that you get right so these
are the types of things that we're going
to look at today images and documents so
you could have MRI images that are
volumetric and you have social media
images social media networks protein
networks gene the gene expression
pathways the database of this CAG
database for example has description
files of proteins of different types of
proteins you have documents and as form
of books or as forms of papers on an
archive for example and so these there's
a wide range of variety of things right
and so quite often the things that
people do write is that we have to sort
of engineer these types of datasets into
something that's machine learning
friendly so we could using the second
learn or any other others popular
machine learning methods and so the
basic question is well how do we know
engineer these data sets in the right
way so that so that we're getting
meaningful results and another related
question is the Big Data data science
machine learning these are very popular
things and a lot of organizations want
to get in on it because they know they
have a lot of data but they don't quite
often have labeled
that's the probably the best use case of
machine learning is supervised learning
still I'm even heard people say that
supervised learning is essentially a
solved problem now you have enough data
you can pretty much get very good models
but you have you haven't here let's say
your library and everything or you have
a series of proteins and just just data
well what do you what do you do right so
be using exploratory data analysis we
were able to kind of explore what's in
here what's the value and potentially
find some interesting insights okay so
now I worked with lab manager she was
actually a media study intersection of
media theory
art history and computer science and
working with other people mornings and
while like me and data Sciences I get to
be in everyone's backyard as I work with
work with art historians and anyone that
has they'd looked right so he has this
had this kind of vision that's that's
that's been actually it's a very popular
idea is that when you do kind of sort of
standard data visualization practices to
take advantage of the case where you
have image collections and do kind of
more high-level types of visualizations
so I'll talk about his series later but
we have this we've been working on this
idea of hiding this image plot this is a
series of libraries that are a Python
code that I've been working on with my
colleague sherry Wong and Damon Crockett
was actually in Chicago now and many
many others and we have this
generalization of a montage image
histogram emerge scatter plots I'll be
showing what those are but that's out
there and there's lots of people who are
actually working on this type of stuff
so I think the open source community has
a huge opportunity to actually make some
serious contributions here we're just
basically just sticking random stuff
together and hope it works right so I'll
go over the classic eight EDA pipe just
to give give some classic overview and
then I'll talk about the specific case
for using eat for collections of images
and then using pi image plot to kind of
just visualize these features and that
if we have time there's a lot slides
actually we'll also talk about looking
at documents and the particular case
that
is investigate up in newspaper documents
over five seconds all right so EDA
actually was coined by this gentleman on
QP and there's this picture just so you
know what it looks like and he has he's
a mathematician he's got a lot of great
things but I really liked his this one
particular quote were you know after all
this math and all this great stuff the
simple graph has brought more
information today data analysis mind
than any other device and I think this
is really true it's awesome
hideous kickers were they were trying to
integrate with other people all the
other teams data scientists and soccer
engine ever trying to collaborate I
think having this communication using
the graph was a very powerful tool and
one of the reasons why the graph is so
powerful I think is this classic example
called ants combs quartets if you
haven't seen this this is for different
data sets to synthetic data set but this
in the real world too so it's four
different data sets that has identical
summary statistics essentially so the
these four different data sets have
identical mean in x and y's identical
variances identical correlations between
x and y's and also their linear
regression is practically the same for
cases right but wise these data sets are
completely different they're very great
different data sets but so there's very
different relationships here they the
data visualization is a very powerful
tool for this reason it's not quite
often when we make these kind of summary
statistics or estimations or
classification models are making a huge
number of assumptions and it's very easy
for these assumptions to fail
all right so EDA this is a process and I
really think this is the fun of data
science so the keynote speaker was I
think having a lot of fun and we were
really having a blast looking at
exploring what is this you know health
record dataset and just finding
answering to think different questions
and having a really conversation and
programming language like Python really
gives you this power to be able to have
a conversation with the data and find
the value in there so the thing is the
two main approaches that we use is this
idea of the physical model it should be
summary statistics or summarizing or
data into basic counts means and
variances and then if you also somehow
visualize the data right I mean and the
nice thing unless summary statistics is
that it's pretty scalable you can write
a couple of lines of code as you saw and
you can get some counts of the most bit
you know the biggest violators of
Chicago's public health laws and and so
it's very very quick and scalable but
visualization the assumptions that you
have to make for it for for for for
running summary statistics but the
problem is that it's rather it's nots
not really scalable to to visualize
every relationship every variable in
your data right
so the typical thing that we do is we
usually look at a couple variables in
our scatter plots or histograms or or
box plots right if you have let's say if
you're just looking at scatter plots and
you have five variables well that's
basically ten three to look at every
little every pair right if you have six
variables yeah 15 pots and anything
after that it really is not really
scalable for us to comprehend so that
that becomes an issue and the classic
thing to do when you have lots of high
dimensional data is to use this manifold
learning or understanding what is the
lower dimensional structure of the data
right and so cycle aaron has a number of
dimensional dimensionality reduction
techniques like pca a principal
component analysis that I'm going to
talk about about a lot there's also a
multi-dimensional scaling for if you if
you want to even non non metric
dimensional scaling is especially
interesting it's used a lot and then of
course a more recent method method as d
tis neat
t this should be this lacasa neighbor
embedding that's that's that's shown
very very promising results for
visualizing high dimensional data sets
so I'm not gonna tech to talk about to
take the technical details of of these
methods but just kind of apply them in
this and see what we get okay so all
these things and everything we talked
about was for this classic kind of
structure of data situation right so
what if you just have a bunch of images
or documents or audio right
so in that case like I said we were
forced to engineer some sort of fee
right figure out how do we represent
these datasets in two rows and columns
and this feature engineering is of
course a huge topic and there's actually
two Wikipedia articles about it there's
this idea of feature engineering and
future learning and the the main
distinction is that future engineering
is when you're using some sort of domain
knowledge or some sort of X some sort of
expertise or prior knowledge and and
you're manually trying to figure out
what are those
interesting features for me to code or
as in future learning you'd like
algorithm the Trece find relevant
features right and so in the case of for
example deep learning when you're
solving supervised learning and future
learning is has been shown to be a very
very effective effective method
but suddenly wanna know what if the
features I've learned or the features of
engineered are they any good
is there any value in there right and so
EDA I think can be used as this very
general pipeline in fact that that we
should apply right is when we have this
data set we have or just collection of
data right in some database or just in
your directory somewhere you extract
these features into into a nice neat
structured data set and then somehow
visualize it and to validate that these
features were good and also figure out
what's in your data right well this is
the general pipeline okay now for for
visualizing these features the classic
thing to do is look at the recipe if you
extract features then it's a high
dimensional vector space then you do PCA
or tis neon on this high dimensional
vector space I need any draw a scatter
plot right so the idea here is if you
have images instead of put instead of
being the scatter plot you instead of
having the dots you actually put an
actual image there right what that image
corresponds to so this is actually my
axes here interpretable this is the open
food data set from a Kaggle if you go to
I only have a bunch of data so no
because we need data so that's open food
and if you I just plotted the
relationship of food that has between
protein and carbon footprint right so
you can see there's a sort of linear
relationship between carbon footprints
and protein so the more beef heavy their
diets are then the more carbon footprint
that tends to have and that's that's
popular and
isten talking about like but he food
item so if we put the the actual image
there you'll notice that some of these
outliers should not keep their chocolate
brand and if you actually look at all
these kind of little outliers the
friends seen that so that's already
something really fishy there right I
think why would chokolate that's that
has a very zero beef essentially a very
have have have such high carbon
footprint so this they either suggest
that this particular company or this
particular brand as has a practice that
is particularly bad or there's something
wrong with this data right so if you're
interested in this kind of thing there's
I run a little LinkedIn article about it
on so just look this up and you can read
more stuff so so you so I try to
visualize these types of things using
setup code that me and my colleagues
have worked on and like I said there's
lots of opportunity here to make this
way better than what it is right this is
like just
version 0 0 minus 1 or something right
though so I'll show a couple of cases
use cases now so here let's look at
images from Twitter right so I think a
lot of people here use Twitter PI data
japako uses Twitter I've noticed and and
so there's people tweet images and they
think they write text and all this sort
of stuff and so there's actually a lot
of a large body of research that shows
that the different types of things that
you will tweet it about there's their
sentiments and the different types of
content tends to reveal something about
the socio-economic characteristics of
that particular location right so in
other words you can actually kind of
predict what the socioeconomic status of
the of a city or a neighborhood is based
on the type of tweets that people do
right so we've been kind of asking a
similar question with our researches is
there anything about the images that
people tweet but also reveal something
about that location or that space and so
this is there's some works there for you
to do if you're interested so if you
just look at the montage visualization
of the images if you use Twitter like I
use Twitter and I just mostly tweet
about the
this stuff and I meet a graph or
something and that you would think that
there should be nothing really
interesting there right and sure enough
you just look at this collection of
pigeons this is just ten thousand images
random sample from I said not even pens
design you a thousand this is less than
that but it's just some small sample of
images from downtown San Diego and and
and there's really not much structure
there right but if we actually organize
these images by the hour of the week and
the day of the week that was posted so
this is each of this is actually a
histogram and each of these little yeah
yeah okay sure sorry to interrupt
we'll have to switch mics Oh Mike also
while we're switching the other room and
showing back up so this is a fascinating
talk you should stay but it's nice all
right
okay any questions make sense so far
okay I mean this is basic very basic but
I think I think kind of powerful because
now he's sort of visualizing these
images that's just the random collection
we're organizing by the date that it was
order time that I was posted right so
each of these so you can't actually zoom
in here cuz this is a very low res image
but we have high-res images offline but
you can zoom in and there is this very
particular structure here right so you
can see that in San Diego and people
really love using Twitter in the Indian
Friday evening and Saturday evening and
then it kind of goes down right and
there's there tends to be two humps here
corresponding to a luncheon and dinner
time right and and we've also each of
these bins we've organized the images by
by the average hue so you can see it
kind of like these interesting mostly
white images are our cluster in the
bottom right okay so that's that's
saying evil what it what we want to know
is our other cities different or are
they the same
so you compared likes it for example to
Philadelphia we also have Chicago I
didn't put it here but but we can look
at it here later if you if you're
interested so you can see Chicago
Philadelphia has a very very different
pattern right and this is again both of
them are 10,000 samples you're seeing
10,000 images from Philadelphia and
10,000 images from San Diego and we're
just organizing it by the time that it
was posted right and so you can see that
there's actually the tweeted images have
a very unique spatial temporal component
without and I used no mathematical model
here I just I just I just plotted stuff
and that's what you see and then
furthermore because we're plotting the
actual image you can see that the
content that people in Philadelphia are
sharing is also different you'll see
that at the bottom there's kind of these
there's significantly more images that
have kind of this white background right
and saying the next thing I actually
zooming into this component then you can
see that in Philadelphia people love to
share these types of images but I don't
even I don't even know what to call them
but but but yeah so so again I use no
math here and it's I think I think it's
quite convincing I could of course in my
paper because I mean we're supposed to
write something right so so I estimate
some feature I do this and I calculate
my p value then yes they're different
right but but but but I think I think I
think this is this is a far more
convincing than some p-value that's like
one time sense and they get it 11 or
something right
so you have we have a similar project
that looks at selfies from five
different cities from five different
global cities from Instagram and and
actually really this was the aim image
histogram was inspired by Mort Stefan
our collaborators of brilliant data
visualization experts and he has an
amazing podcast on the other
visualization we should check check out
and so they go to selfie city dotnet you
can actually explore these datasets and
interactive but I wanted the Python kind
of implementation they let you explore
these images this was sort of a one-time
kind of thing I think that's the time it
was okay so so kind of reviewing again
so we had a collection of images we
extract some feature
and then we visualize it right so in the
previous case the peaches are just
basically metadata right it's just the
time that it was posted and maybe
average you so that's some color
histogram that's our futures right but
if you have a question of images you
really need to be using deep learning
like like it's it's it's good stuff back
then it's it's it's really quite
impressive how well it works and so so
it's you might sound like a trend or a
buzzword or something but but it's it's
really quite fascinating so so the thing
is that this is still I think not even
it's it's been known for a couple of
years now at least but it's still not
wildly no known widely enough I think
and that's that these deep networks that
you're learning they're it's their
hierarchical and their layering features
on upon futures iPhone features and of
course at the last layer there's this
classification layer that should be your
classification but it turns out these
hierarchical futures that are learning
that they're actually very useful and it
can be used for other tasks and if you I
think you know maybe 10 years ago
particularly in class or something it
would that would say that ok if you
build your model based on the data that
model is only relevant for that for the
statistical assumptions on that dataset
if you move that model to different data
set there's no guarantee that you could
you would get anything meaningful right
but in the case of deep learning we've
used this for art images we've used them
on satellite images we've use them on
shoes on very very different types of
images that have very different
sophistical characteristics then the
image and that data so that's this
controlled data set and we're getting
very very impressive results right so
all we're doing is basically we're
extracting features from these pre
trained neural networks that were
trained on imagenet essentially and
using it for our applications right and
and it's giving us quite phenomenal
results so you can you should download
cafe it's very difficult to get it set
up I had to get a lot of help to get to
get a set up on our machines but but but
we have great help and so to piece it up
cafe for us and cafe well the reason you
like these at the time when we started
this this this work was that that
the the library that had a bunch of
pre-trained networks available from this
so-called model Zoo github repo that
they have a they have a repository of
all different types of pre-trained
networks similarly there is another
project called deep detect that has a
bunch of networks that have been trained
on different types of datasets so
essentially you can download these
networks for free and then extract the
features from them and then visualize
your image collections so we've we've
seen a couple of presentations on
writing pipelines so there scikit-learn
friendly because I could learn how this
amazing pipeline and this amazing API so
I was doing a lot of kind of feature
extraction I was using this Cafe library
a lot and I used to I could learn a lot
so I made something called ski capping
all right just this for myself but then
it's funny because you write something
for yourself and then other people start
using it too and it's like okay
this is kind of a thing now when I say I
think you want me like three other
people so like it's not but but yeah so
so it's actually this is this and I
think I think there's been some talks
about this already that you can you can
write your own wrapper that you are your
own estimator or your own classifier
using psychic burns amazing API and now
you can kind of integrate this with with
other your your standard machine
learning pipe pipe pipe line right so so
the basic thing that that you do is you
first using the OS module I didn't do
you might correct so I'm not sharing my
import section sorry that's that's
probably crucial but but but essentially
you just in the work cakes that I have
and I think a lot of people have you
have collection of images lying
somewhere in some directory somewhere
and then you just load all the images
you just essentially cursive Li walk
through that's your source path and then
you just you just check to see if it's
within your image if it's one of these
image types right and then so ski cafe
what I but I what I do there is I just
have to specify where is cafe located
and then I specify the
the market essentially the model
architecture this is the model
architecture files if this is a ResNet
architecture and then and then the two
train parameters of that model so you
have these two files that you download
from from the Berkley model Zoo and then
you kind of pass this into ski cafe and
that gives you essentially a deep
learning model right really a future
extractors it's really good just an
estimator and see your your fit which in
this case just loading the parameter
networks and then and then you transform
your future which is a list of image
paths into a two into an um Piper array
or optionally have a flag that lets you
output into a panther theta right so so
essentially you give it a list of image
paths and then you get a numpy array out
that's now your structured data and now
you can do machine learning okay so let
me show an example of that now so so we
have this there's this there are many
many base stations in San Diego
I collect data because we have a
wildfire problem you also have you know
you have a drought problem yeah we have
a lot of problems but it's a great city
and and so the wonderful thing is we
have these base stations that collect
temperature pressure all sorts of things
and also there's a camera that takes an
image every minute as we gather this
kind of awesome dataset that's just
images every minute it's a time-lapse
like great photography or video and so
this is like one particular scene where
an image is being taken every day right
so you have all these images which is
lying your heart hard drive well what do
you do with it right so if you just
apply this kind of pipeline where you
just load the images extract these
features and then do do a basic PCA and
see what you get right so this is kind
of what you get for from one day this is
one day of data and this is the PCU
again but of course instead of putting
dots we're putting the actual image that
was that was posted there right and and
if we if you have a good big monitor and
stuff then you can zoom in it's really
fun but but here just just bear with me
with this low res image right so you can
see kind of there's like these two nice
clusters this is basically all the
nighttime photographs that that's us
they're all they're all clustered well
together and then this is kind of the
I think here I just show like a kind of
a zoomed in version of it and so you can
see this is just that same photograph
that I showed here right that's like the
middle of today kind of kind of thing
right so that's just like first and you
see there's basically two modes right
there's my time and then there's like
mostly daytime and then a transition
between these two modes so that makes
sense and I think this is a reasonable
feature you go to July 2nd again you get
something pretty reasonable so this
suggests that it's robust to different
days remember of different days have
different weather conditions and there's
clouds and different things and it's
they're still primarily two modes right
slightly different but because there's
different cut stuff right is clouds and
everything so it's not gonna be exactly
the same but it's pretty much the same
and then if you go to July 3rd it's
totally different
alright so so so what happened in July
3rd and if we kind of zoom in here you
see that there was actually a fire I'm
July 3rd so so we have no label data we
have nothing and and and but but but
just by you visualizing this then it's
very very clear that's the distribution
and the temporal aspects of this these
features change a lot based on this
crazy event that happens right
fortunately the firefighters came in
very early and nothing bad happened but
but we got cool data so and of course I
have to just pay a respects that this
idea of visualizing images in this way
is not new and it goes back to I think
the earliest example I could find was
Francis Galton this scientist and I have
to put his picture it's important I
guess and and it's a half cousin of
Darwin alright kind of interesting and
so he did a lot of stuff some bad stuff
too but but his interesting work here he
was like some eugenics guy I don't know
so it kind of kind of weird stuff but he
so this is England and he's plotting the
actual wind direction and currents as a
kind of little figure on top of England
to visualize how that looks like the
distribution of the winds and currents
so so again no idea is the original it
goes back to many many years so this is
certainly there's nothing you have
happening so I want to say ok so here
now I'm going to switch gears to looking
at collections of documents that was
images
and for everything but the pipeline is
essentially the same you load your files
and you extract some sort of feature and
then you visualize it with PCA or some
dimensionality reduction technique
alright so in for in the case of
documents the most popular feature is
one of the most popular features is this
charming frequency feature that has
essentially counts the number of words
that that occur in each document and and
so you get this one long feature vector
that's that's that's that's that depends
on the number of words in your
vocabulary so you could visualize each
of these documents with the word cloud
whether a lot of data is experts who
hate or clouds I don't feel so strongly
about it but yeah I mean if you just I
think I think you have to be careful who
your audience is
so anyone ever risk anything I'm not
showing anywhere close so there we go
and and but then the perhaps a more
meaningful text feature is the problem
with this if it features if you have a
common words like stop wars such as or
and maybe are not interesting they tend
to appear superficially important all
right so we'd like to somehow normalize
these words to be less important and so
this term frequency inverse document
frequency feature is very popular so
essentially we're taking the charm
counts that we had and we normalized it
by this by this by this wait that's
essentially the half and the word occurs
in other documents
right so though occurs in a lot of
documents and we want to bring its
weight down that's what this term
essentially those here okay so here the
case study that we're looking at is as
newspapers in UC San Diego so I think
someone during the rent I don't know
they're here but they said I think they
work in library Sciences defended the
scientists who don't share the data
because because of copyright issues so
so that's definitely a big big issue but
but what's what's amazing is actually a
lot of data that's that has no copyright
and
and so and libraries are actually
digitizing these data sets and make me
available for research or whatever we
want to do with it right so for example
UC San Diego that's a pretty new school
or out relatively new school but they
they've had this you know see the
newspapers there's like two two versions
of them there's this UCSD Guardian
that's the official campus paper that
gets funding from the University or or
has like a very official thing and then
there's like independent things that
people do on their own like a like a
zine or zine and it's about kind of just
random stuff but but but but but but so
we have this data set and it's been
digitized and I think every library has
a beta so I had no idea that they that
libraries actually did this well we have
like tax we have maybe also record music
so we have I think 40 years of audio
recordings with the scores that the
performers have record so that's that's
that's a lot of interesting data data
applications really made there so check
out your local library they could be
something cool datasets not just books
and so what was great about working on
this project is I was working with a
humanist Aaron glasses that was a he was
a humanist and she kind of want to
investigate it to say that and my
intuition as a machine learning guy is
well okay I should use this because it's
like it has like equations and math and
like it since I could learn so I should
like use it right this SSS machine right
but then when you work with someone as a
domain expert and has a different
perspective you get just very refreshing
questions so she had she just posed this
very interesting question that was like
well what is the term frequency between
the gendered pronouns right what is is
there a difference between the number of
times the word he was used and the
number of times the word she was used
and I thought wow that's a really
interesting question I mean if you would
think that it shouldn't be that
different and it's a pretty easy regex
thing so I should you know yeah it's
like we should just do it if they would
you should see if there is a
relationship between the he count unless
she count and then I can't with this
amazing equation which is just this the
key count versus the she count but then
I have a laplacian scaling alright so
the foods you don't have divide by zero
right that's all I do and and this
essentially over
doing is that for each issue we count
the number of keys in the count number
cheese and we have a different corporate
right we have a the official UCSD
Guardian newspaper and then we have the
official easiest the soudanese papers or
unofficial if to say student newspapers
and we want to know is there a
difference between these counts of
ratios for these two different corpora
right and how do these ratios change
over time that's that's the basic
question so you just use your regex and
you get a plot like this and so this is
he / she so equality would be here at
one and you can see that in the early
60s mid sixties he counts she by order
own you know order of magnitude and
attends to go down and these actually
average over the year so that so there's
the data is I couldn't fit everything
into one kind of slide here but
essentially he's always out numbering
sheep I like a piece of factor of two
even even even out here it's out of them
occur a factor of two but if you study
the name a little closer there is kind
of these like sometimes it goes up
sometimes it goes down and and so it
seems to be a seasonal component to it
every every four years or something or
so which is kind of a funny number
because the course wants to either
presidential elections or or different
student bodies coming in and out and and
so so so what's clear though is that
there's there's a very wide gender gap
that's persistent now what we want to
know is what about other newspapers
across the country other other other
university student newspapers there are
the ones that are more perhaps diverse
or equal or well what is what is driving
of this and the other thing it would be
interesting I think is that be so quite
often I think these these articles we
looked at of them a little bit of tharid
they did they tend to be talking about
men that's what they used to war he
makes sense right but but I think this
year is very interesting they only have
up to twenty fourteen but hopefully
we'll get more this this is the first
time where a woman is running for
president
right
so you really just can see if it would
actually be a more equality order or a
significant shift so it remains to be
seen but but but this it's a very
interesting year I think so then of
course I have to try my tf-idf stuff
right because it's like I gotta be
something so so I extract let's see if
idea and again do you do the PCA to see
if there's anything valuable in or
interesting sitting here and so this is
this is kind of what we gets is to each
of these dots and these are all
interactive or plot neat plots that are
interactive and so this is what what the
distribution of the issues looks like
for student newspapers and this is what
the distribution of issues looks like
for the UCSD Guardian and I've
color-coded based on the decade that it
was published right each of these issues
were published and with with the student
newspapers you don't see quite as strong
a temporal components but the UCSD
Guardian is a very very strong temporal
component so like the there's there's
there's a radical shift between
essentially topics or Ward distributions
throughout different decades so of
course now we have to investigate what
are the workers that are driving the
changes is it is this noise what are we
observing here but at a high level we
this is we're already forming these
hypotheses and and humanists can
investigate kind of interesting outlier
years like for example you go back here
right like in this particular year
there's the huge like athletic what why
is that year an outlier why is this year
an outlier and so we can focus our
attention on particular key points okay
I'm almost almost done
what we discussed was a basic EDA
pipeline that I think should be the
first thing and probably the first thing
you do every day and you have a new data
so just to review your assumptions and
then create these plots
share with your team and then your team
quite often has different backgrounds
but everyone understand plots so it's
very important and we talked about
visualizing collections of images and
looking at some documents all right so
I'd like to thank my colleagues sherry
Wong daemon crocodile anonymous Jay Chou
Larry Smarr and also instapure applied
math of UCLA for partially supporting
this and thank you yes
oh so the question is how
computationally intensive is it to
produce the image plots so if you're
looking at the order of 10,000 or so
images not very it's this and it's not
it's not an issue at all
and I think you say if you want to like
the millions which we have done that
could that Mia thinks well we still want
everything on a laptop
so it's essentially be definitely
definitely steal things but even if you
do a million or if you show a plot of an
image plot of a million points versus
like I say a hundred thousand points the
human eye can't really tell the
difference so that's at some point it
doesn't even really matter so you have
to you're forced to take a sample of
your data great thank you